mr. Donald Trump jr. are you there can
you hear us sir you know it's kind of
weird because we're watching your your
father right now and then it's a very
similar face but on the brawny man shirt
well you know you pull it off well after
the two weeks in quarantine I have like
a weird Tiger Army rockabilly hairdo and
my wife won't have sex with me it's a
really thank you for outing me okay so
listen I don't know how much you know
what we're doing but because obviously
the the press briefing wasn't but it
turned into a press briefing and a
wonderful one by the way a lot of people
missed it because it happened earlier in
the day we've been doing this and we've
been doing two shows every day for the
month of quarantine and we've watched
all the briefings and then we've all
been pulling our hair out watching CNN
after we're going I can't believe
they're painting it this way so today
we're watching this as though it's live
even though it was earlier so that most
people can see it for themselves and
then live fact-checking CNN for four
hours let me let me ask you this Donald
Trump jr.
what do you prefer mr. jr. mr. Trump jr.
yes okay mr. down all right Don Don um
before your family lived in New York
obviously you have to play yet to play
nice with both the right and the left
for a very long time and I know that you
used to appear on CNN and so did sort of
your dad how would you describe that
transition now in the way that they've
treated him and and how you view the
media considering you were such a big
part of it with such big shows for so
long so that was always a little bit of
an interesting navigation you know that
said yeah I'll be candid like the first
political fundraising thing I ever did
was for Andrew Cuomo when he was running
for AG right you know back in the day so
you know again when you're a real estate
developer you know the Attorney General
signs off on offering plans on anything
that you're gonna do to get bail you
know so you do have to play that game I
think it's why my father was well suited
to kind of jump into that system because
he knows exactly how it works
you know and so many people don't you
know this is not a pure system by any
any means right uh uh you know watching
it now I mean I did CNN because you know
I think they were at least somewhat fair
to us you know back before my father won
because they wanted him to be the
nominee because he was the path of least
resistance right for crooked yeah so it
wasn't like they were being you know
honest where they were being magnanimous
or that they were being you know
impartial or you know bipartisan they
were hoping to debt Trump there so that
she could destroy him you know what's
funny
I first off I love that you refer to
your father by his last name and said
you're like don don Trump you're the
Dwight Don King magnanimous outrageous
lascivious all right so switching
switching gears here because you've been
on Twitter I've been following you and
and you've really been on the Michael
Flynn thing I want to ask you why are
the handwritten notes in the documents
that were released yesterday why are
they so important and and what does it
tell us about or what should people see
in there about the motives behind Flynn
because it seems like I've really it's
really complicated story to a lot of
people so if you can distill it for them
honestly you know basically the first
time I've said it upon public I'm pretty
loud anyway huh you know I take a
position on a lot of stuff I get pretty
aggressive and I don't you know sort of
toe the line I sort of usually you fly
across it and Michael's women and it's
probably the one issue that I've
actually been reasonably quiet on until
I saw this stuff starting to come out
right for the last few years it's one of
my biggest regrets frankly over the last
few years and it because Wow even me
who's been on the receiving end of that
[ __ ] meaning you know I was the
number two target of the Muller
investigation I don't think anyone's
contesting that right I played it a
little differently I was a little bit
more aggressive I did everything my
lawyers told me not to do I was mad I
went on back I talked [ __ ]
you know my lawyers were like you're
you're killing us here and in two years
later they actually said you were right
they go done you know what you were
actually right because the other side
had no intention of trying to get to the
truth right it was always about that so
by you fighting back you sort of put
yourself in a position where they were
getting I could have rolled over and
died and they would have shown the
exactly zero quarter right and that's
the way they left fights they do a much
better job of that then you know the
right yeah the right has a tendency of
rolling over and dying at the first sign
of a little bit of resistance and you
know I think that's why my father's been
able to get through some of those things
so my big regret with when was not
taking a stronger position in favor of
him now I knew he did it I knew what
they tried to do to me I got a little
bit luckier in you know whatever it was
whether it was strategy or willingness
to push back ability to pay insane
amounts of legal fees whatever it may be
but when I see what happened now I say
man even me even with that experience I
still had a hard time believing in
reconciling then these guys could be
that crooked that they could go so far
out of their way to set up a guy that is
certain meaning I just like there has to
be like truth that I pause there has to
be something there and that's why I want
to go all-in on this issue right and now
let's see those notes and it's like why
don't we try to get what's the objective
to try to get them to live so we can
fire and get him to lie so if we keep
trying to kill it Trump get him to do
this I mean the only objective they had
no interest in was truth right nothing
to do with the truth yeah it was a setup
now again you saw that from the page
rock stuff start from Brennan who can
lie in front of Congress and Comey and
all of these sanctimonious [ __ ] oh
[Applause]
come on
yeah I'm amazing silent is sanctimonious
and yes he is he's been pretty quiet in
the fact that these guys aren't in jail
when we start seeing what's coming out
now and if I do what I can only imagine
will come out in the next few weeks as
they start to release these things but
what I want to know is for the last few
years the FBI has been sitting on these
things knowing
they're knowing it's exculpatory
evidence not giving it to flims legal
team basically if it wasn't for his
legal team being aggressive and being
like wait a second there's gotta be
bored of this and pushing and pushing
and pushing this guy would have signed
his life away because they presumably
they went after his kid like they did to
me trying to hurt my father
I mean it was it was a very similar deal
and you know I wish I would have been
more aggressive about it but it was even
hard for me is just a reasonable
American right to assume that these
people could be such corrupt well and
let me let me ask you this do you think
it was hard for you as well because
unlike yourself I mean flain effectively
had admitted guilt because he was right
now again whether he was railroaded
whatever it was he was doing the other
they tried making I'm seem like a bad
actor because you know he was in general
for 30 years he gave a speech and Turkey
and they hate him oh you know you work
your life to hold now you have an
ability to do that like it was nothing
wrong with it but they made it seem like
it was so wrong I don't like man I don't
know if I can jump in on this like it
it's just it's truly disgusting it's
really disheartening yeah and this is
not a reflection on the door kickers at
the FBI always got to make that clear
because then you know CNN runs the guy
Jr hates agents I don't mean agents I
hate the guys that don't carry guns
right bureaucrats at the top the guys
that got there by being the biggest
[ __ ] not the door kickers I mean this
you are like the the kim jeong-hoon to
your dad Kim but I mean that in the best
way like you are all the good parts of
your dad except Kim Jong Yul had no
redeeming qualities don't get fit but
you are like turned up to an eleven in
that you're like you know what I don't
really care I don't really need to be
appreciated by the video I please run I
can say what so many of us are actually
making and I just don't care if they try
to cancel me they've been trying to been
trying to throw me in jail like you know
getting canceled is like the least of my
concerns right although in jail getting
canceled
euphemistic mate so I would still keep
you know keep your head on a swivel but
I tell you what I would chop off my arms
and legs I would be you I would just be
nobbling on the show if you were to run
for governor of Michigan and kick that
Whitmer out that is a fight that I would
so love to see I know it's just it's one
of those matchups like a gorilla versus
a grizzly bear but oh my god that's a
dream of mine I don't know you know I
think she could have done a lot more
permission there's a difference right
she you know it'd be one thing if it was
she probably had every bad decision from
Michigan because she wasn't worried
about Michigan she was running for VP
for the last two months right so every
TV appearance everything that she could
do to try to attack Trump the only thing
she forgot about was her constituency
minor details if you're the governor
[Laughter]
like the reality is like I would love
her to be the VP pick because like you
just have a case after case of literally
ignoring the people it is her job to
take care of so that she could either
bolster Joe Biden I mean the amount of
stories that I'm hearing about people
that they couldn't get PPP in Michigan
because she didn't take the declaration
seriously so they got in line two weeks
behind literally 350 million other
Americans that were vying for the same
stuff I lost out I mean she's done a
major disservice to the people of her
state just being a partisan hack oh yeah
she's been absolutely terrible um let me
ask you this kind of enclose I know
you're busy and we have to get we have
we're late looks like you got a question
is a happy
I mean grab a bill so you know you
you've been a longtime business man not
only in the areas of real estate but the
businesses that are served by commercial
real estate not only in the city of New
York but in the state and around the
country what what type of message do you
have for those folks who are sitting
there right now you have tenants you
have workers of tenants restaurant
workers businesses who are saying we
need to get back to work and it's not a
partisan thing he knows his own resume
how that's true what what do you what do
you have is a message for those folks
hey no one wants to get back to work
more than me
you know and I'm in that world I mean
we're in hospitality you know you have
an 800 room hotel with two people
staying in there let me get it's just
not a good business model right you know
I want to get back to work and it's not
just to make money for me it's I also
want to put the people that have been
our employees people who have been you
know we've had to have some conversation
get them back to work but you saw I mean
the partisan hackery so we are a hotel
company we were specifically excluded
from being able to take advantage of any
of the funds or any of the programs and
literally any other hotel in America
could take advantage of but we were
gonna expand you know it wasn't like my
father was negotiating in favor of
hotels are trying to get something for
us but the Democrats carved us out of
that so Jay Pritzker who's the governor
of Illinois but happens to own Hyatt
Hotels no problem there's nothing to see
here
right you know they did that big thing
we're like well we'll carve out members
of Congress members of Congress who have
no other businesses no other this you
know because they're just trying to hurt
Trump now it's not gonna hurt me it's
gonna hurt the thousands of people we
actually employ because we do actually
employ real people right I mean we have
some in New York Chuck Schumer is
probably hurting some of his voters yeah
he's constituents by literally trying to
penalize Trump because that's what you
got to do so you know it's it's a sad
world in which we live but we do have to
get back we have to do this safe way I'm
not downplaying the severity of some of
this thing especially in certain areas
right right I mean where's New York
City's the epicenter of you know outside
of Wuhan New York City is the American
epicenter now that could have been
California that could have been
Washington New York City got it worse or
Hanna whatever it may be
um I don't think that should start off
the same now I have a cab in an upstate
New York and I know a lot of people in
there they don't know anyone who's had
it anyone who's brought it they don't
know of a single case but they also are
shut down there two and a half hours
outside of the city right well you know
I don't think you have to hold them to
the same standard that you do New York
City now you maybe encourage people from
New York City where a sick don't go
there don't bring it with you
there but like you know it's not even a
state-by-state solution I think my
father's been really good about sort of
saying hey I believe in the Constitution
I believe in sort of federalism gonna
let the governors decide for their
states but the governor's probably also
can't decide city by city they look at
these things you know it's not one state
you can open all of upstate New York and
probably not add any fire I don't know
if you're there yet for New York City
but you know we got to start making
those can I ask you a where you don't
come back from it it's a little scary
now watching the Democrats petition for
bailouts not for anything that it
relates to coab in nineteen but for
literally stupid and reckless spending
decisions over a decade right yeah
they held up they held up the small
business stimulus right when they wanted
to get their little earmarks in and now
they cannot beg for the money fast
enough for their states and actually
your father talked we didn't get there
because this is tape to live where he
talked about I think I love your daddy
said now the Republican governors he
said they're not asking for bailouts you
can call it luck or Talent
maybe it's just a different rate with
ease or maybe just a different frame of
mind but that's the reality you know hey
said you know we're never gonna let a
good crisis go to waste so the left will
definitely try to make up for decades of
mismanagement spending yeah well I think
that's an important note by the way
because that state equivalency is very
similar to what we talked about you know
comparing short of the Obama stimulus
versus what happened right now you know
with the cove in nineteen right
effectively the federal government
stepped in and when we in the absence of
data rightfully so said hey listen we
need to stop things right now we need
people to slow down that was the
government intervening and so it's the
government's responsibility to make sure
that these businesses can stay afloat
that's not the same as bailing out
American Airlines for the umpteenth time
because they spent money irresponsibly
and people need to draw that delineation
between we're shutting you down
you can't just say I'm gonna force these
situations on you and then
congratulations you're on your own but
you know and again you know even even
some of the states that have done that
to us we can't take advantage of it
because we're trumple we're always gonna
be held to a different standard because
you know that's the nature of the
political game but it's only a political
game not because of any logical reason
right can I ask you one question so one
thing I will say that that does so like
he said where none of us are saying the
vibe just like your dad and the
President did not say the virus was a
hoax he was talking about the media
trying to lay the blame at his feet as a
hoax and of course doing the bidding for
China but one thing I do wonder you know
especially considering the antibody
testing that is coming out now and even
Cuomo himself I believe saying that the
mortality rate is it revised it to 0.5%
and likely lower for young people when
do you think we'll start seeing some of
those revised numbers in these these
press conferences because I'm always I
hate to say it but slightly disappointed
that that info isn't getting out to more
Americans because it's important for
them to know a lot of them still may
think that it's a four percent mortality
rate and we know it's not you know sort
of figuring this out now I mean some of
these things I'm seeing back New York
you know 20 percent of people have it I
was like well you know 20 percent it's a
lot different 20 percent of New York
with 13 million people or whatever it is
right you know so millions have it
you're you're right it's it's
significantly you know more negligible
and then you hear have the cases well
hospitals are getting paid at more money
if someone dies of komen so it's like
yeah let's you know let's just I wanna
you know what's gonna be the interesting
statistic it's gonna be what happened
Stephen at the end of the year when we
find out how few people actually died of
the regular flu because I have a feeling
I have a feeling the Blues statistics
will go to virtually zero but Trump will
not get credit for that right but I have
a feeling that flu will go virtually to
zero to bolster these numbers so the
whole thing you know it already has
actually we covered that on the show it
already has the last couple of months
not exactly zero but the flu deaths have
gone down drastically right and because
they're all being registered as kovat 19
and some people try to argue well that's
because of social distancing it would
have long been before social distancing
could have had an effect because of that
rubber band effect so it's already
happening yeah reality
you know in the areas that you know I
don't know that anyone got bombarded as
badly as they were possibly anticipating
it they don't don't don't forget no
one's talking about this success story
that Donald Trump has had because they
said two million people were gonna die
and we're at what 140th of that you know
it yeah you know whatever whatever the
exact math is but like we I think
they've done an amazing job they won't
talk about that they won't talk about
Donald Trump in January 20 a said hey
this probably makes sense let's shut
down travel from the epicenter of the
outbreak wins Chuck Schumer that's
racist it's premature it's too
aggressive I don't like if you're
looking for your people is it that
literally the number one in you connect
Donald Jr the Don jr. if I'm a Nancy
Pelosi and de Blasio were shooting
videos tic TOCs like the famous nurses
now from Chinatown encouraging people to
eat out in Chinatown no I don't know
exactly what it's like in New York or
San Francisco but I'm from Montreal
where we have one hell of a Chinatown I
wouldn't eat out at in Chinatown when
there isn't a pandemic way to lay a
landmine to be clear Donald Trump jr.
loved his jet he loves his General Tso's
chicken okay we're all very clear as I'm
just saying you know like Chinatown
Montreal trying to dump put your stuff
in the refrigerator would be nice about
the point so it's the that Donald Trump
could take probably the action that
certainly slow to flatten the curve
better than anything we could have done
while we were preparing for potentially
this onslaught that never quite happened
the way it did in certain areas but not
certainly what they were predicting
right yeah two million deaths is you
know it's a big difference than where
we're are not one of these again should
happen if China was honest if China
spent more time and more money trying to
feed their people rather than stealing
our military technology no yes maybe
people wouldn't have to eat that and if
people were
you know these are minor details that no
one's willing to say my dad is not a
minor D that's one hell of a detail
worrying about trying to save face look
powerful in front of the world you know
they managed to shut down travel I'm
hearing to Beijing and Shanghai from
Wuhan but they let everyone else play
all over the world you know what this
crisis has taught us is that frankly
Donald Trump was more right in 2016 than
we ever knew and I believed he was damn
right then but we have to have some
control of these things we have to have
control of our borders our supply chains
we have to have American manufacturing I
mean you had the Chinese literally
threatening to withhold the antibiotics
that American companies developed
although we manufacture them there for
some strange reason they're gonna
withhold sending our stuff to us during
a crisis because we're not blindly
adhering to the Communist party's
propaganda after they literally lied and
put the world in this place and I'm
watching mainstream media be like oh no
this is from the Chinese government not
a single case that is too far you cannot
I mean why are we imbeciles well to be
fair in Don lemons defense I think that
he actually is his IQ is at the point
where he might he might be eligible for
special grants but I will say this
support yeah that is that is something
that is very important we actually I was
live on air right we did this morning
show this month and so some of this were
checking news as it comes in and I was
reading a quote regarding the World
Health Organization and I was reading a
quote regarding Donald Trump wanting to
pull funding from the World Health
Organization it was a statement from
Chinese ambassador and it happened while
I was on air and I read it and I just
said well of course they're gonna react
that way and you guys remember off air I
said wait a second wait a second was
that lily and G Zhang whatever his name
was I said wait was that the was that
the Communist propagandist who blamed
the the coronavirus on our own troops
and an hour after I was on air I said
wait hold on a second
yes that's the guy who spread the
conspiracy theory that our troops
started the coronavirus and he was cited
he was quoted in Washington Post in New
York Times Forbes late
but not just quoted and then like you
know hit hard quoted as though it was
gospel right what the one guy you know
that no one's gonna call him a
conservative but you know Jonathan Swan
from Axios actually interviewed the
ambassador and asked him but those
questions like and the guys were I can't
speak for that ago but this guy is a
blue checkmark verified spokesperson for
the Chinese government when he say well
that's not my job I'm like no God and
Swan did a good job of sort of hitting
but the interview got literally no
traction other than people like myself
on social being like has anyone like
thought about watching this because like
this is literally someone finally
calling them out asking them simple
questions about the propaganda that
they've been spreading yeah and they
literally I like a bumbling answer that
was nothing it was inside I'll give you
one more and then I have to go and have
one final question but actually when we
ran I don't know about you but the
scariest thing this month the thing for
me that really made me think there's
something more sinister afoot with the
media rather than just ignorance right
because sometimes people are just
ignorant you have your Don lemons in
your brian Stelter do the work they
don't know anything but then you have
people who are actually trying to
subvert the truth and it was that
interview and it only had a few hundred
maybe a couple thousand plays when we
ran it on the show where this Asian
reporter asked the World Health
Organization about Taiwan on skype and
he said sorry the phone the skype cut
out I couldn't hear you
and she asked again about Taiwan and
their refusal to recognize Taiwan and he
just hung up live on air and no one
covered it and we showed that on air
after that you know it got millions of
plays and I know that you you do this
job as well but sometimes to for me when
I look at something like this and I go I
feel I feel chills running down my spine
not like Chris Matthews when Barack
Obama listen you see you know obviously
that's that's an extreme version but
honestly we're seeing the same thing
just in the way but the left handle said
who is it
like risk resilience name is on CNN
today or literally did a piece asking
about the Tara Reid
you know accusations against Joe Biden
now it was a liberal like about as
liberal as it gets on CNN he brought it
up on his show no it wasn't too far it
wasn't aggressive it was not nearly what
he
have done to Brett Kavanaugh or Donald
Trump under similar circumstances but he
brought it up and within minutes
trending on Twitter was left-wing people
trying to get a leftist fired from CNN
right Jorge is breaking up a question
that if Donald Trump or a Republican did
would be let's call it the huge with a
capital of why Corey Oh here yeah and
they're literally trying to get a goober
leftist fired for even mentioning an
accusation that literally has
corroboration from thirty years ago much
more credible than anything these
bastards through it Brett Kavanaugh you
know where they did seven hundred pieces
on something we're just like well so
when did it happen where did it happen
what year was it I mean give me a break
already it's insanity
right so this guy asked a simple
question mentioned what should be the
biggest story of the day with perhaps
the exception of Corona and they tried
to fire him I mean this is what we're up
against and it's also why the right
loses all the time because right the
left will sacrifice any morality any
decency any principles to try to win and
push their [ __ ] agenda and you know
we don't play the same way and I think
we probably should wait does that mean
it's curtain is getting the Muppet Kane
from the final question to two questions
court two-part question when you get
this way guilfoyle how are you exactly
have a little bit more decency and
that's fine you can you can I just
scream
such a good mood I be mom with you he's
like super excited so this is him in a
good mood well that's my that's my final
question because we do have to go but my
final two questions its Part A Part B a
is this genetic because I notice you do
this as well and B when you're at
Thanksgiving do you say to your dad
Donald Trump please pass the potatoes
[Laughter]
you know with some of these one-liners
that these press conferences you got to
sit at like a family holiday
if you don't worry about like just a lot
of alpha personalities around the table
vying for dominance it's pretty awesome
I mean yes it sounds I I accept your
invite okay well thank you so much
I obviously you have to get back to your
lovely lady there and your wonderful
upstate hopefully you're heavily armed
because you know you just told people
that you're the president's son in
upstate New York so especially with Bill
Gates contact tracing software that is
absolute you and you know what I will be
as well after we watch the Bill Gates
Town Hall on CNN so thank you so much
Donald Trump jr. we really appreciate
taking the time brother be safe thank
you better you than me enjoy that